what is up people of the world it is
Jerry I am on my way to Ryan writes
place to should review of the film I
just got out of which is Godzilla 2014
yes that's correct Godzilla's back he's
big and bad and stuff alright so I gotta
get some out of the way first there
needs to be no confusion because we have
two directors of similar names who
present it to prominence recently so as
not to get confused with Gareth Evans
who was behind the ever-popular rape
movies this film is directed by a guy
called Gareth Edwards gareth edwards is
responsible for a movie i really want to
see I haven't seen yet club monsters as
an independent film that he did a whole
bunch of money like wrote directed and
edited and and I think even acted in it
maybe he did like a lot of the VFX stuff
so I haven't seen that movie like I said
but it seemed like from everything I've
heard about it that Gareth Edwards would
be a very cool and interesting choice
for Godzilla and um I think that rings
true i was a bit worried going in like
all I don't know are they gonna let him
you know be creative with this and it
seems like they did I really enjoyed
this movie I really do and I don't want
to talk in too much depth about it
because part of what was so great about
it was just the amount of things that
surprised me that I wasn't expecting I
tried to stay away from most all the
promotional material for this like I do
with most
you know I'd seen the trailer a while
ago a couple times and I saw one clip
very tiny like literally very small on
one of Ryan's video so that's all I'd
seen for this movie and I'm really happy
about that and from what I can tell from
its advertising they actually do a
really good job of pitching you the mood
and then the vibe of the movie while
still really concealing a one of the the
secrets and stuff there were a lot of
characters I wasn't expecting to be
prominent a lot of things that happen
that just wasn't you know exactly the
kind of movie I was expecting and I'm
really happy about that this feels like
an honest Godzilla movie and it feels
like it was made with a lot of love i
really like the cast Aaron Johnson I
thought was really good Bryan Cranston
is always really good ken watanabe I
really liked I just really liked what he
did with the the performance David's
truth erin elizabeth Olsen everybody
who's who's in this prominently does a
really good job and the movie really
does rest on its on its cast because so
much of it is locked into their
perspective which keeps this from I
really like this if a grim but just if
ago you know is kind of like a Godzilla
vs. robots kind of a thing a lot of
people were talking about Godzilla with
that movie came out in this movie really
avoids being that sort of thing while
still delivering on what felt to me like
a very appropriate amount of monster
action I can understand how some people
might feel as I've heard it said that
there's not enough Godzilla or there's
not enough action personally I thought
they handled it really well and that
partly comes from how they chose to
anchor the story i guess i would say
this movie has a very sort of dready
tone like it is very it's not like
overly seriously it still manages to be
fun but it does have this you no sense
of dry it's a monster movie you know
it's so the monster
is vague and ominous and and everything
sort of goes to support that the visual
look of the film Seamus McGarvey the
cinematography is really good um it's
it's not necessarily like flashy but
it's really well capture there are a lot
of gorgeous shots and it really clever
transitions and things like that on the
camera just just the way the movie is
composed visually is really flowing and
really well well done the music as well
the score by alexander this bla is I
thought fantastic it has this very retro
throwback vibe there's a lot of brass
and stuff like that a lot of the
instruments that you don't hear as much
any anymore or in these kinds of movies
now so that was a real treat as far as
I'm concerned anyway and the way the
film sort of zips back and forth between
different characters and even glimpses
into these little moments with people
around and stuff like that I thought was
really cool so really everything kind of
works together for me in making this a
really successful movie you know I
really like the actors I really like the
stories they got there are so many
really clever transitions and really
clever little glimpses you get into the
lives of the people who are going
through this um so yeah I'm really glad
it worked out and you know I'm excited
to talk about with Ryan see what he
thought but I love this movie I think
highly recommended so let's talk about
this if you've seen the film what did
you think obviously and what's your
favorite Godzilla movie let's let's talk
about that because there are so many
cuz it was kind of like the James Bond
of monsters so uh yeah that's it for now
Godzilla is the film I am Jerry cheers
you